un établissement scolaire sous haute
sécurité car depuis quelques jours c'est
ici que sont déposés les migrants
l'école secondaire Basset fait partie
d'un des trois endroits transformés en
centre de détention à elle passe au
interdiction pour les caméras d'y entrer
puis soudain apparaît une famille le
pouce levé avec un grand sourire ce sont
les premières sorties soupirent de
soulagement après avoir passé leur
première nuit à El Paso ces deux
familles vénézuéliennes sont libérées
ce premier moment de liberté
Caroline c'est la matriarque avec ses
deux filles et son petit-fils Alex de 11
mois
à l'ombre sa fille qui n'a pas voulu
donner son nom à l'aide son bébé elle
reste discrète sur les circonstances de
leur migration sa sœur elle caresse déjà
des rêves d'étudiants en médecine
par la porte 42 dit-elle dieu merci ils
nous ont libérés avec nos documents mais
nous n'avons pas d'argent pour aller à
Chicago nous allons marcher vers
l'église pour voir si on peut avoir un
billet
à la porte 42 à attendre
le bruit courait ce jour là qu'après
minuit ne serait plus possible d'accéder
à la frontière
au marché d'un pays à l'autre sur des
roches placées sur le fleuve sous le
regard de la garde nationale les soldats
avaient beau renforcés les barbelés rien
pour décourager les migrants
aujourd'hui le lieu est désert ils ont
tous été transportés à El Paso oui
on traite les demandes on fait un triage
et s'ils n'ont pas la base pour rester
ici dit-il on les renvoie
c'est le chaos dit le président de la
Chambre des Représentants
on est plongé dans une autre crise Joe
Biden a été à la frontière qu'une seule
fois en 50 ans il va y avoir du chaos
pour quelques temps
pour le moment on est très loin du chaos
de ce côté de la frontière il y a eu
très
peu donc combien de temps
elle passe au